Leslie I know that you've received the
banning of the film in India you've
received maybe notifications on Twitter
or various things advice for another
filmmaker that is making a motion alee
politically-charged film and still wants
to carry on a very very important
message and has the help of others
around them but just dealing with that
in general what is your advice because
I'm sure there's many other filmmakers
whether it's something no blackfish you
know an arrow Morris film this there's
probably so many others that have been
in your shoes but it's not something
that's you could just pick up a book and
and find out how to deal with it my
advice is simply this commit one hundred
percent do not shy away from telling the
truth in whatever form of expression
that takes if you care about this
message just tell the truth because
apathy and silence and all forms of
negotiating the truth because it's not
quite tasteful or it's a little bit
shocking shop is a powerful tool shock
is important we don't have enough of
that we don't hear the truth enough
we've become so annoyed two concepts
that that really deal with the most
fundamental violations of human rights
and we've become so used to them FGM we
give them little acronyms you know they
trip off the tongue so easily FGM FGM
let us not forget what that is a knife
is taken the clitoris of a woman is cut
out her labia a cut off I spoke to us a
Malian girl the other day who told me
that one of the practices as amongst
husbands and wives is that if a husband
will go off on a business trip he will
show his wife up he'll come back and cut
the stitches this is what we're talking
about and the world is what ignoring
this it's accepting it we have to scream
out we also have
do not think how will I be allowed to do
this we have to think who's going to
stop me from doing this and you know
it's it's the most important thing
always is with filmmaking i think is is
committing yourself to the truth and
passion and integrity of what you feel
because you know there were moments
where i wanted to give up there was one
day where i was giving up there was no
question nothing in the world was going
to keep me there except i happen to
phone when i thought my kids were asleep
and thought i would get my husband i was
in the midst of a major panic attack and
i think it was really it was not long
after I'd interviewed a rapist who had
raped a five-year-old girl and that just
so drenched me in the deepest sense of
profound pity for the world that you
know given the state that we are in that
that can happen and that this man could
have told me so easily that he did this
because she was a beggar girl and her
life was of no value and I was so so
depressed by all this that I think that
must have led to this breakdown and I
phoned home literally to tell my husband
to book the flight because I didn't even
have the presence of mind to do that and
my daughter had answered the phone and
she immediately knew that I was in
trouble and asked me what was wrong and
I then just burst out crying I couldn't
control myself she then started talking
me down off this panic attack with
breathing exercises huh she was 13 and a
half when she did this and then her
final statement to me after telling me
to write all my problems down and then
start solving the little ones first so
she gave me some very practical advice
and then she said to me and mummy you're
not coming home because I and my
generation of girls are relying on you
and that was it so I stayed but that day
I really was going to stop and
badly wanted to but you know the the
thing is that there are so many when
you're dealing with a difficult subject
like this there are so many reasons to
stop and not do it and there are so many
obstacles physical practical emotional
psychological that unless you have that
real compulsion humanness will not start
so once you have that fire in the belly
just go with it and go all the way and
if you go all the way that message will
get through as it's getting through here
I mean this film has sparked more
conversations about gender inequality
and this issue this pressing urgent
issue of how women and girls are treated
in every country in the world to
differing degrees and with different
characteristics its spark more of those
conversations in the last five months
then have been hurt in the last decade
so that can only be a good thing and I
think it's because of the shock it's
because of the one hundred percent
commitment and you know I mean if I if I
die doing this my time on earth will
have been worthwhile so when i get these
tweets you know white you deserve
to be raped or threats to my life or
pornography being sent I just tell
myself fly 30,000 feet above this this
will change when the solution is put
into effect and I have got the solution
i have to tell you because of the
insights and the perspective of having
delved so deep with such commitment into
this particular inquiry and i just have
to tell myself that you know these are
pathetic backward-looking people who are
very soon going to be left behind when
there will be new learning and the world
will change